Chris de he's an NHS whistleblower who's
now working as an ane locum doctor also
here dr. Adam Dolby who is a junior
doctor and is now not supporting
tomorrow's action welcome to you both
dr. Dhabi you've gone through a bit of
an evolution on this action you were
supporting me a lot now why's that um I
looked at the contract in the hall when
it was released on the 31st of March
this year and took a view that the
contract itself was actually quite good
it had guardians in place it had a
thirteen and a half percent pay increase
I believe that the extended working week
is something that we we do have to deal
with unfortunately if we are to help
with the delivery of an NHS that works
seven days which is really what the
government's trying to introduce and it
has a democratic mandate to do that dr.
Chris day there has been progress made
as we heard from dr. Dolby there the pay
issue has to a certain degree win result
hasn't it 13.5% there are more
concessions for weekend working so what
is the problem well I think this
situation for me
boils down to should we as a nation be
opposing or even opposing vigorously
what is being done to the NHS and by
that I mean should the junior doctor
contract dispute be seen in a wider
context so if you take the the fact and
that we're short of nurses you know why
on earth would you get rid of the
nursing bursary if you're short of money
you know we we read of all these NH has
trusts in deficit why on earth would you
buy your spanking new hospital on PFI
huge interest rate I mean very when we
are short of money I mean we've got a
national deficit we've got austerity
we've got taxes going up where do you
think the money should come from and and
how much well I'd love to just finish
what I just said respectfully and if you
don't mind I made it clear that you
think there are a whole series of
shortages in the health service and you
obviously think there should be a
priority for the government I'm asking
what you think no that's not
that's normal I said I said there's a
deficit in NHS trusts they've chosen to
by spanking hospitals at high interest
rates they pay eight times the value of
the hospital back as part of PFI schemes
I'm just saying you know I'm giving you
a wider context I will focus on the
junior doctor contract dispute but you
know we've heard a shortage of nurseries
getting with the nursing bursaries we've
heard of Hospital trust borrowing at
wild interest rates and then I'd come to
the Health and Social Care Act which has
taken the legal duty of the government
to provide health care you a politician
you're not a doctor you're taking on the
entire health policy I mean do you think
it's a star a certain the Health Service
doctor Dolby no I don't I think that a
junior doctors contract dispute is not
the appropriate place to be having a
serious conversation about the future of
our NHS I love our NHS I think it's a
marvelous institution and it's something
I'm very proud of it makes me proud to
be British but it's it's not in the
context of a contract dispute something
that should be discussed in that arena
so it should be just focused in on the
contract dispute and we can have a
sensible balanced rational argument with
with strong with strong heads and
cross-party hopefully but is there any
hope of having any sensible rational
debate in argument when you've got the
BMA and you've got Jeremy Hunt and they
are diametrically opposed and both have
said we're not giving ground
I think they've both back to each other
and backed themselves into a corner the
BMA have come out strongly and and have
really gone for it in terms of publicity
and they've tried to get the public on
side quite vigorously and also to try
and get the junior doctors onside quite
vigorously as well
they actually got them onside with
claims of a 30 percent pay cut which
turned out not to be true and that that
calculate was then removed from the vmas
website at a later date
Gerry Meehan has has tried to negotiate
with the BMA and I'm not here to defend
the government's position at all their
communication hasn't been great and
there are still some question there's no
way we can negotiate when there's a
contract being imposed when there's
imposition still on the table
but they've had chance to negotiate
they've been able to to come come around
a table and you've got to give some in
negotiation purse has just become
political dr. quest oh okay um so ID
politicize it and focus on the contract
because I realize I should focus on the
contract well no it's just let me just
say what I think about the contract
because I realize this is what this is
about so the contract was imposed
without an impact assessment so that
that that's actually susceptible to a
legal challenge
you know mr. hunt should have shown what
is defined as due regard and he did his
impact assessment after the event so
that's that it's potentially unlawful
can be challenged yes they'll challenge
it but and then the be amazed position
is mr. hunt all you need to do is to
stop this strike is to potentially go
back on what is an unlawful act which is
in position without any quality
assessment so that's the first thing I'd
say second thing I'd say is the contract
discriminates
the way the pay progression is and the
way that doctors are paid for their
hourly rate out of hours is such that it
gives a pay a pay cut to junior doctors
of the women and junior doctors at all
long term sickly now let me just say one
more thing and then I promise you our
our to your question
the other thing is it discriminates
against specialities so acute
specialities like emergency medicine
that are already short-staffed with the
way the paper aggression and the hourly
rates structured they will get a pay cut
we already don't have enough doctors in
those speciality see the problem is it
seems to me that the various
justifications who've been offered by
the BMA and spokesmen we've taught to
keep on shifting I mean originally it
was a pay cut then it was because of
long hours being worked and dangers now
you've come up with specific things and
at the end of all this bearing in mind
that many many people do work at
weekends in other professions without
any rewards my question to you is is a
strike which means that people are going
to suffer really the way to address
these issues well I can I mean I work in
emergency medicine so I can only
tackle the emergency medicine context of
that question and I can simply say that
you know in in the emergency departments
there will be more consultants around
you will literally get a consultant
delivered care so there's a huge
argument your care will improve and
you're averaging on that basis we don't
need junior doctors ever I mean we'll
just get the consultants to do all the
well it's interesting you should say
that because they're there to train
aren't they you know from a service
delivery of course we prefer consultants
to deliver our care but we're with the
consultants of the future come from and
that's the dichotomy isn't it between
training and service delivery should
also say that the contract doesn't have
whistleblowing protections so doc junior
doctors can't actually do unfair
dismissal claims with that contract you
obviously don't think a strike is the
way to do it no and especially not I
mean I know the the impact assessment
hasn't been done and it's can be legally
challenged but that legal challenge
should go ahead before the strike action
takes place logically it doesn't make
any sense to do even if you believe in
strike action which I don't but you did
I did I did at the time I did I had a VM
a proper gamma I think I'm right in
saying that about 40 percent of junior
doctors are not striking is that right
we did we don't hear that but I mean a
lot a lot a lot of you registrar's and
others it was I think it was around 40
percent for the for the the previous
strikes that didn't include accident
emergency okay gentlemen thank you very
much indeed dr. Adam Dolby and dr. Chris
day thank you thank you thank you